uau boa tarde
bobeira que eu não vejo ninguém é bom eu
vejo esse tempo que correndo
é bonito disse que a gente não leva mais
objetivo que a gente queira ser nada a
gente leva senão a nossa história de
vida né
e é um pouco que eu vim contar pra vocês
a minha história com o psicólogo como
encontrei os doutores da alegria e que
isso me ensinou sobre saúde e sobre
formação
eu trouxe essa mala é comigo é essa mala
é eu coloquei nela quando minha filha
tinha três anos de idade ela tem 18
quando ela tinha três anos de idade me
convidaram na escola dela pra falar o
que eu fazia
nessa época eu já trabalhava com os
palhaços e eu levei essa mala com vários
objetos que os doutores da alegria
usavam e pra mim acho que foi um dos
momentos mais difíceis de falar do meu
trabalho então eu trouxe ela hoje comigo
porque eu acho que ela é montada com a
uma situação muito bacana que eu vivi e
acho que hoje a gente vai falar vou
tentar falar aqui um pouco sobre o que é
e mantha essas relações
eu trabalhei vários anos no instituto do
coração como psicóloga hospitalar
fazendo a preparação de pacientes para a
cirurgia
muitas coisas que a gente aprende no
hospital
a gente aprende a através de sinais que
não os verbais e eu me lembro que a
primeira vez é que eu me deparei com a
morte no hospital
foi um desses eventos era mais ou menos
três horas da tarde eu estava com meu
prontuário trabalhando na unidade
coronariana tinha acabado de atender um
paciente e primeiro você escuta um som
de um instrumento que desabilita um
pouco daqueles pt e os passos dos
profissionais correndo a movimentação a
rotina que se abre
depois os aparelhos que entram toda a
o procedimento para tentar uma
reanimação e depois você de novo escuto
silêncio não é um aparelho - esses
profissionais que voltam para os seus
postos para trabalhar a fazerem
anotações e eu me lembro que aquela
tarde quando isso aconteceu é por algum
motivo eu me aproximei quis me aproximar
do leito e eu cheguei bem perto daquele
paciente que tinha acabado de falecer
não era um paciente que estava atendendo
e quando eu fiz esse movimento de chegar
perto algo estranho aconteceu é como se
eu tivesse entrado numa outra zona do
tempo
se eu pudesse entender se pode ser um
dos próximos momentos dele também
conectado a uma família que receberia
notícia e ao mesmo tempo me conectando
com o passado dele teria sido esse homem
depois ele teria construído para a vida
dele
isso durou muito pouco 11 segundos e o
meio passe de novo para trás naquele que
é como se eu tivesse novamente no mundo
dos jalecos brancos as pessoas agindo
normalmente os médicos trabalhando as
enfermeiras mais ou menos como se nada
tivesse acontecido
isso era um pouco a minha vivência
cotidiana do trabalho dentro do hospital
tinha um fluxo de vida do qual nós
profissionais de saúde não
participávamos não conseguimos nem
tinham sidos formados na universidade
para entrar em contato com esse fluxo de
vida em 91 eu conheci o wellington
nogueira que é o fundador dos doutores
da alegria é um trabalho que leva
palhaços profissionais dos hospitais
duas vezes no semana de maneira contínua
eles têm um trabalho ininterrupto nos
hospitais com alta formação profissional
para isso welinton e 91 é ouvir uma mata
na televisão enfim eu acabei chegando
nele e ele me convidou este trabalho e
quando eu fui este trabalho é como se eu
tivesse entrado novamente naquele lugar
que eu tinha vivido com esse paciente
que havia falecido
mas dessa maneira eu pude ver isso de
uma maneira não esquizofrênica é como se
aquele lugar ele pudesse estar conectado
com a vida do hospital
eu lembro que o que mais me chamou a
atenção a primeira vez que eu vi o
trabalho dos doutores da alegria foi a
flexibilidade que eles tinham no contato
com a criança eles são muito bem
preparados tecnicamente mas a técnica é
invisível
eles então se eles propõem algo ea
criança não está a fim daqueles
rapidamente se desfazem daquilo e tentam
uma nova forma de se relacionar com ela
eles se permitem está num certo vazio no
início da relação poder construí lá
isso pra mim era muito novo eu como
provocou um profissional de saúde com um
psicólogo apesar de estar ligado à área
de humanas
quando eu entrava no quarto tudo que o
paciente falava eu ia colocar isso
dentro de uma hipótese diagnóstica né eu
precisava de um esquizofrênico de um
deprimido pra poder me relacionar e
construir o meu diagnóstico e aquilo era
muito novo pra mim
em 93 o era então me convidou para fazer
parte do grupo na época já era 18
artistas é ele me convidou para fazer
parte de apoio emocional e junto com
isso eu comecei um trabalho de pesquisa
que dura até hoje
esse trabalho tem várias fases é dois
livros publicados uma tese de mestrado
mas rapidamente só tem 18 minutos eu vou
resumir um pouco o que o que o coletei
esses anos todos né
os dados convergem para algumas coisas
em comum por exemplo as crianças ficam
mais ativas passam a se comunicar mais
com os pais e com os profissionais saúde
aceitam melhor exames e medicamentos
as crianças que estão no hospital dia
com ciro a cirurgias de curto tempo de
internação têm os seus sinais é vitais
deambular é comer
elas adquirem sinais mais rapidamente
para prata é alta
além disso é eu observei que o trabalho
tem um efeito importante para os pais e
para os profissionais de saúde os pais
ficam mais confiantes no tratamento
porque eles podem
o filho dele mais próximo do que em casa
porque ele está brincando né é um é um
jeito mais mas em particular seu né de
ser isso devolve a confiança de que o
tratamento vai dar certo
os profissionais de saúde relata uma
diminuição do estresse no dia a dia de
trabalho é é uma melhora a auto imagem
como profissional o que por exemplo se
uma enfermeira está próximo ou médico
ele é
os artistas têm nem a incorporá-la e
incorporá-los na brincadeira e com isso
eles podem se perceber não só como
aquela pessoa que está ali para dar a
medicação mas também pode brincar com a
criança depois que eu comecei o meu
beijo na época do meu mestrado e comecei
a estudar a questão do humor que eu acho
que é a primeira coisa que chama a
atenção do trabalho dos doutores da
alegria mas muitas vezes eu ia no
hospital e não necessariamente eu ria
tinha outras emoções que aconteciam
tanto comigo quanto às pessoas que
viviam a experiência de ter contato com
os artistas e no mestrado eu me deparei
com uma definição de espinosa sobre a
alegria que eu acho que fala muito sobre
o trabalho que os artistas fazem no
hospital
espinosa disse que tudo o que existe são
encontros ea capacidade da gente afetar
esse afetado por esses encontros se
esses encontros aumenta o meu porteiro a
minha potência de ação eu experimento
alegria
se esses encontros diminui a minha
potência de ação eu experimento a
tristeza
então para o espinosa toda ética deveria
ser a ética da alegria do que ele chama
as paixões alegre é diferente da moral a
gente deveria se ligar por essa ética né
e as paixões triste pra eles seriam
todos os sentimentos que estão ligados à
piedade no egito que é preciso ver o
outro como um coitadinho né
ou as fotos e hierarquias onde o outro
não está no mesmo nível que eu bom
porque palhaços né
esse movimento é um movimento que
cresceu muito no mundo e no brasil
com chris em que foi quem criou essa
metodologia em 86 o que o que ele foi
capaz de perceber né que viralizou hoje
você tem esse trabalho no mundo inteiro
fortemente na europa é e no brasil a
gente tem mais de 1.200 grupos que fazem
essa atividade não como fim porque
muitos desses grupos as pessoas
trabalham de maneira voluntária e não a
têm a preparação profissional por fazer
isso mas como um meio de levar alguma
coisa então eu fico me perguntando por
que porque o palhaço entra no cenário
contemporâneo é o palhaço ele é ele tem
ele tem uma máscara e essa máscara é a
autorização que ele tenha da sociedade
para funcionar de um determinado modo o
palhaço permite que a gente entre em
contato com os nossos sentimentos
permite que coisas que normalmente não
seriam ditas possam ser expressas né
ele brinca com as figuras de autoridade
por exemplo no caso dos doutores da
alegria ele usou um jaleco branco é e se
colocam como médicos né e brincam com
essa com com essa posição e com isso
eles permitem que você possa dizer
coisas que normalmente não seriam ditos
é o palhaço abraça o erro a ambigüidade
tudo isso são é ingredientes alimento
pra que ele dá lhe possa nascer a graça
essa alegria da qual eu falei o que
palhaço tem a ver com formação não é
porque estou aqui tentando juntando os
dois temas né
é eu diria pra mim é uma coisa muito
importante que eu aprendi isso fosse
resumir o que eu aprendi com os doutores
eu aprendi que uma série de coisas que
nomeava no hospital de depressão
hospitalista é todas essas eram questões
que tinham muito mais a ver com a
dificuldade
os profissionais de saúde tínhamos de
entrar em contato com os pacientes do
que algo que efetivamente tivesse
acontecendo com aquele paciente e os
doutores da alegria propõe na minha
opinião é o que eu chamo de uma ética do
encontro através do modo de ver o mundo
o palhaço nos propõe a entrar num outro
tipo de encontro e eu acho que isso que
atrai tantas pessoas a a brincar um
pouco com essa figura do fenômeno que
acontece no brasil é que grande parte
desses 1.200 grupos são de estudantes
estudantes universitários de medicina é
de outras áreas de saúde e o que eu
percebo trabalhando na formação com eles
é que a gente tem a oportunidade de
criar um outro espaço pedagógico é um
espaço pedagógico onde o corpo e os
sentimentos são bases estruturantes para
eu aprender alguma coisa onde a
experiência que eu vivo é a coisa mais
importante é a ser considerada onde o
erro a ambiguidade a confusão são etapas
do do aprendizado é um aprendizado que
reconecta é o o aprender com com a vida
ordem do humano eu acho que a gente viu
isso em outras apresentações a
necessidade que isso aconteça a gente
falar de fato em conhecimento é eu
gostaria de ler um conto pra vocês que
eu trouxe
é um conto do gonçalo tavares é um
angolano um ponto bem curtinho se chama
o casaco o casaco como acreditava que
tinha um anjo protetor no seu casaco
nunca de espiã
quando quiseram recrutar para batalha
ele disse logo que sim desde que pudesse
combater com o casaco vestido o casaco
tem lá dentro um anjo que me protege
justificou
claro que exigirá arquivos militares não
aceitaram ninguém combate sem uniforme
o homem do casaco insistiu mas nada
feito
não aceitaram ficou em casa
os soldados que entraram na batalha
morreram todos
eu trouxe esse conto porque é eu acho
que esse casaco do qual o gonçalo
falando conto é esse lugar do sutil do
invisível é o sentimento da
individualidade todos os lugares
de uma maneira geral no ensino
a gente vai colocar para fora porque o
saber
ele está ligado algo que está fora de
mim é dado de de fora pra dentro
esse novo espaço pedagógico essa
possibilidade de vestir é de não usar só
o uniforme mas de poder levar consigo o
seu casaco eu acho que fala dessa
possibilidade de construir uma
universidade do futuro onde a
individualidade de vocês vai poder
construir uma profissionalidade e não ao
contrário então o que eu queria com esse
ponto é desejar pra vocês que vocês
possam ir pras suas batalhas quando
forem solicitados que vocês usem os seus
uniformes mas que vocês possam também
levar os seus casacos
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]